wow i just read an astounding article
called on the same wavelength
it was published in aeon magazine
written by a philosopher of mind
and it was about the human need
for what he describes as emotional
synchrony
emotional synchrony is
another uh way of describing
what i often have called the
inter-subjective
or what the jewish mystic martin buber
calls
i thou relationship so emotional
synchrony is the feeling that two people
are having a common experience we're
both attending
to the same thing our two subjectivities
temporarily stitched
together to be as one
right an experience of emotional
synchrony sometimes happens
when you watch a movie they call this
the diactic
shift when you get immersed or
transfixed by the film you assume
the viewpoint of the character and now
you're seeing what he's
seeing you're seeing the same thing now
you are
emotionally attuned to the character and
so you're invested in the outcome of the
film
this extends of course to interpersonal
relationships in fact it plays out
in interpersonal relationships with a
resolution
that can bond us to people and is
ultimately what makes us
uniquely human unique in the animal
kingdom so
this emotional attunement this emotional
synchrony that transpires
when you feel connected with another
person again is about having
what jamie wheel calls comunitas a
common
experience two very different people who
live in very different
mind worlds temporarily assume the same
viewpoint they become attuned to each
other and
the author in the article spent some
time
exciting examples of how young babies
you know from when they're
born up until the 18 months you know
they they go through this developmental
process of early face-to-face
communication what it calls
proto-communication that eventually
evolves to the capacity of the infant to
point to things in the environment so
then it becomes a face
to face to object communication whereby
the child can look to you for an
emotional
attunement to make sure we're having the
same experience sharing the same
content and then can point to something
in the field can point to an object in
the world and then check in with you to
see what your emotional
attunement and connection is to the
object to make sure you're on the same
page to make sure you're on the same
wavelength so it points out to the fact
that for
human beings this emotional need for
attunement for synchrony this empathy
must
lie in fact at the root of our
astounding capacity for language
linguistics rationality everything
that makes us miraculous the mysteries
of who we are
are born he feels from this this
capacity for empathy and for
inter-subjective and emotional
attunement and emotional
synchrony again what martin buber calls
i thou
you know this feeling of the
inter-subjective when two subjectivities
assume
the same viewpoint it's like it's like
when we say to somebody
do you know what i mean you know do you
know what i mean i did this and i did
that and i loved it and you know what i
mean and i kissed the girl and you know
what i mean we keep saying do you know
what i mean
do you see what i mean are you with me
are you on the same wavelength are we
vibing
are we on the same note you feel me
you get me we want to be gotten and this
need
to be gotten to know that the person is
on the same page they're seeing what
we're seeing they're
on the same wavelength this
is emotional synchrony and it is at the
root
of what makes us human so definitely
look up the article in a on magazine i'm
sure you can just google
emotional synchrony aeon magazine
amazing article on the same
wavelength i think is the title but man
it really spoke to me because
particularly
my love of uh of experiences of ecstasy
are accompanied by a desire a compulsion
to share those experiences like
when i'm in the throngs of of
of of engrossment when i'm transfixed by
beauty truth and light i always turn to
my friend
to make sure he's with me to make sure
we're having that experience the
the compulsion to make sure we're
connecting
accompanies all ecstatic and elated
experiences when i'm transfixed by
wonder
i want to make sure you're with me and
so this article just spoke to me and i
think it also
is at the root of where my desire to
make these videos come from because what
i'm doing is i'm
making sure you feel me i'm summoning
coherence in the bardos between one
statement and another to make sure this
is
landing to make sure you're on the same
page to make sure you're on
the same wavelength with me so it turns
out this this emotional
synchrony this need for emotional
synchrony it really it just
it really landed for me i read the
article and i was like wow this guy's in
my head
so anyway it was a really an amazing
enlightened afternoon enlightening
afternoon to read that and i wanted to
share with you
um what a concept
emotional synchrony
to be on the same wavelength to know
what we mean
to know that we that you know for me to
know that you know what i mean and that
you know that i know what you mean this
is a magical thing
explain so much all right that's it
have a beautiful day